ODIN
Do you swear to guard the Nine Realms?
THOR
I swear.
ODIN
And do you swear to preserve the peace?
THOR
I swear.
KEVIN FEIGE
One of the early decisions we made
at Marvel Studios was bringing on Thor.
And we always knew we wanted to find
an amazing performer who had the chops
to perform this character as we saw him.
We looked the world over,
and we found Chris Hemsworth.
CHRIS HEMSWORTH
This world is my punishment.
It's my punishment for
my endless pursuit of glory.
KEVIN FEIGE
The way Chris did it, we thought,
"Okay, this is gonna work."
NATALIE PORTMAN
It's really, really just impressive to
watch him work. He's so committed
and works so hard. He has such incredible
comedic talent as well.
THOR
This drink, I like it. Another!
Is that the best you can do?
ANNOUNCER
Chris Hemsworth as Thor!
CHRIS HEMSWORTH
This is what it's all about, you know,
is coming, meeting the people who love
the characters more than anyone
and so that's a very,
very special thing.
[Laughing]
TESSA THOMPSON
It really is inspiring because he is
brave enough to
try things and see what sticks.
TAIKA WAITITI
When I came on to do Ragnarok,
I basically just said, "Look, man,
you just got to be more of yourself."
"It would make the
character more relatable and funny."
THOR
I swear I'm not even moving,
it's just doing this on its own.
TAIKA WAITITI
I think that's what you want
in a Super Hero.
THOR
Yes!
CHRIS HEMSWORTH
I have loved every single time I've
played the character.
This is ten years now.
To have the opportunity to do another one
is just mind blowing. You know?
It's gonna be incredible.
THOR
What a classic Thor adventure!
ZEUS
And flick!
[Crowd gasping]
KORG
Oh.
THOR
You flicked too hard, damn it!